so for example they give us this
now the way i read this right is five
times a number and they're just calling
the number
x because they don't know what it is
five times a number
gives four thousand
and this is simply saying well okay what
is the number okay yeah
um
okay sure i'm glad we had this
conversation now how then am i going to
get the number the most direct way is to
think about what you can do
to both sides of this equation that'll
get x
on its own okay we're trying to we're
trying to sort of corner
and beat them up a dark alley yeah
yeah okay so because i've multiplied x
by five here i want to divide i wanted
to buy it right
so i'm going to write this out in two
lines i'm gonna go 5x
divided by five that'll get rid of the
five on this side
but you can't just do it to one side and
not the other that's a bit unfair isn't
it
so i'm going to divide by five on this
side
also so that'll get rid of five there i
just have an x
four thousand divided by five whoo eight
hundred eight hundred good and that was
a good note well done okay so that's
what it is in this case
now in this case we had to divide in
other examples you have to do
you know multiplication for instance um
so for instance if i had um
let's let's do another example if i had
x
over 7 equals
10 okay i don't want to divide by
anything in this case because that would
make this
you know even further away from what i
want instead i should
multiply both sides by the denominator
which is seven
so i would go seven times x
on seven that'll get rid of that over
seven equals
ten times seven yeah um x equals eight
hundred
yay well done
congratulations okay yeah
okay so from this line to this line what
i'm trying to do
is i'm trying to get the x on its own
or by itself okay
mathematically the techie way of saying
that is make x
the subject so sometimes you'll hear
people say
change the subject of the equation which
means i want set to say
x equals blah right i want to get the x
by itself
okay so you'll see you'll see this
phrase what they really mean is that
the way to do that to get rid of the 7
is i have to multiply by a number
okay here you divide it here i multiply